Hogwarts legacy's character creator has
been fully revealed including that
mysterious final tab that had only been
teased thus far of course we've gotten
bits and pieces along the way regarding
the Character Creator but it wasn't
until the recent gameplay showcase that
Avalanche fully revealed the Character
Creator options with the help of expecto
go our favorite Merlin conspiracy
theorist Avalanche gave us a detailed
walkthrough of how the Character Creator
will work in the first tab we have a
look at presets and these appear to be
randomly generated presets using various
hairstyles and skin tones as well as two
clothing options this is where you'll
start and I really like this approach
because some players really just want to
get into the game as quickly as possible
and not fine-tune every single detail so
the presets give you that option now I
know for a lot of you listening to this
your jaw may be on the floor that's kind
of hard to believe what they don't want
to customize every single detail some
people don't you know they just want to
jump right in now if you want to really
get into the further customization
options and I assume most of you
watching this video want to do exactly
that then the preset will simply serve
as your Baseline so you can simply
please select one of the options that
are in the ballpark of what you're going
for then you move to the next tab which
is the faceware tab it's here you can
set the face shape skin color and
whether or not you want glasses under
the face shape category we have 15
different options to choose from and
these appear to adjust features like
your nose cheekbones forehead etc for me
I actually think this is a good amount
of control without being overwhelming
now if you're a big gamer and you play a
lot of games in this genre then you are
probably used to having a lot more
control over things like the nose the
chin the cheekbones even the ears I
think here it's pretty clear the team at
Avalanche wanted to go with something a
little bit easier to digest with a focus
on not overwhelming the player but still
trying to give us plenty of variation on
our character then we move to skin color
and there are 20 different options here
which you select by moving the
horizontal slider back and forth after
that you have the option of giving your
character glasses and we start with the
circular spectacles for that Harry
Potter look then we have the half moon
spectacles for a more Dumbledore style
look and then a third option which is
kind of like a hexagon style of glasses
now if this doesn't seem like a lot of
options when it comes to the glasses
don't worry because game director Alan 2
mentioned that through the course of the
game there's a lot of other options
you'll keep unlocking remember all those
shops and hogsmead I'm guessing that's
where we're gonna be able to find some
of those it's also worth noting that
Alan was asked near the end of the
Showcase about what you can or can't
change about the character once you've
started the game so according to him
details like the accessories the glasses
as well as the hair can change looks
like we're gonna have a barber shop in
hogsmead but it sounds like the main
character features like the face shape
and skin tone cannot be changed moving
on to the next page and what I think is
the star of the show in this character
creator the hairstyles you'll start by
picking the hair color at the top and
there are 32 total options then you move
down to the actual hairstyles themselves
and I tried to look through the menu
here and count them all I believe there
are 47 different options and most of
these are just stunning the texture in
the hair just has this level of detail
realism particularly for people of color
that you just don't see in most games
trust me I see all of your comments
about this and I know the team at
Avalanche has seen this as well I think
it's just really impressive what they've
done here and I know it was an important
Focus for the team that worked on the
Character Creator on the next tab we
have complexion and it's here you'll be
able to adjust the complexion as well as
freckles moles and then scars and
markings the complexion was a little bit
interesting since we already had skin
tones but it appears to be a more subtle
adjustment to the skin giving you the
option to darken the eyes a little bit
or shade the cheeks it appears there are
nine options for that category looks
like 10 options in the middle here for
freckles and moles and then we have nine
options for scars and markings with the
first option here just being no scars or
markings at all the next tab is all
about the eyes and we'll have
adjustments for eye color eyebrow color
and then eyebrow shape I counted 25
options on the eye color 33 for eyebrows
and then we have 20 options for eyebrow
shape including the very last one here
which appears to be no eyebrows at all
and then we move to the final tab which
to this point has been a complete
mystery the main title of this tab is
finalize your character and it's here
you'll choose between two tones of voice
and then be able to adjust the pitch of
your character's voice we officially
have four confirmed difficulty options
with your usual easy normal and hard
difficulties but also a story option
which is actually a step below easy this
is intended for those Potter fans or
anyone playing Hogwarts Legacy who
aren't usually Gamers but still want to
play this game because of being able to
go back to Hogwarts as our very own
witch or wizard we also get to see brief
definitions for each one starting with
story which is said to be a focus on
story with minimal gameplay challenge
easy if you play on easy you'll get a
light gameplay challenge normal a
balanced gameplay Challenge and finally
hard a demanding gameplay challenge
after setting the difficulty you'll get
to name your character that's right
first and last name this is a big one
that puts to rest some of the
speculation we had as fans about whether
or not we'd be a witch or wizard from a
specific family this would also seem to
rule out anyone calling us out by our
name in the game and to be fair I know
it's possible there are some games
before particularly sports games who
have actually programmed a number of
names into the game but I would not
expect that here for Hogwarts Legacy and
and finally you'll choose whether you
want to be a witch or Wizard and this is
the choice that will determine your
player character's dormitory from there
you'll be off to Hogwarts to experience
an original story from The Wizarding
World set in the late 1800s if you want
to get caught up on everything we know
about the lore and Story So Far check
out that video on the right side of your
screen now as always thank you all so
much for watching I'll talk to you again
soon